This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。保证真人。在“回首过往”播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。请在爱荷华电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回首过往”。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听“艰难求生”，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你就必须这么做，请在爱荷华电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“艰难求生”。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lepinian. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你在这个特定的测试上做了两次手脚，对吗？我对测试做了一次手脚。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱皮尼安。我震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“受困之爱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在爱荷华电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“受困之爱”播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的方法。让自己经历一些磨难，你将会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己迎接新生。请收听“2%”。即数字TWO，在爱荷华电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Speck and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Before we get into it, I want to let you guys know that this episode you're about to listen to
我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。请在爱荷华电台、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“女朋友们。相信我，宝贝”。大家好。我是杰玛·斯佩克，欢迎回到“20多岁的心理学”，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时最大的改变、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。在深入探讨之前，我想告诉大家，你即将收听的这一集
is also on YouTube. Yes, we now do video podcasts over on YouTube. So if you prefer to watch episodes rather than listen to them, go and check it out. There will be a link in the description. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, or listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're going to talk about the psychology of toxic habits, the little rituals that, you know, we swear we're going to quit, the behaviors that we hide, that we justify, that we laugh off, the ones that make us promise ourselves, like tomorrow it's going to be different. You know, when I turn 27, I'm going to quit smoking. When I turn 28,
也可以在YouTube上观看。是的，我们现在在YouTube上做视频播客了。所以，如果你比起听播客更喜欢看视频，去看看吧。简介里会有一个链接。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新老听众们，无论你们身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们也会剖析20多岁时的心理。今天，我们要聊聊不良习惯的心理学，那些我们（你知道的）发誓要戒掉的小仪式，我们隐藏的、合理的、一笑置之的行为，那些让我们向自己保证的行为，比如明天就会不一样了。你知道的，等我27岁时，我就戒烟。等我28岁时，
I'm going to quit drinking. And then surprisingly, it never happens. and, you know, it could be procrastination, it could be smoking, it could be using your phone way too often, it could be self-sabotaging, we're going to cover them all. I think what's so difficult about these toxic habits is that so often, let's be honest, like we want to stop. And we really do want to, you know, create a good future for ourselves in our 20s. And we simply can't, not because we don't know any better, not because we don't care about ourselves, but because our brains are doing what they've been trained to do.
我要戒酒。然后令人惊讶的是，它从未发生过。而且，你知道的，这可能是拖延症，可能是抽烟，可能是过于频繁地刷手机，可能是自我挫败，我们都会讲到。我认为这些不良习惯最难对付的地方在于，通常情况下，说实话，我们是想停下来的。而且我们是真的想在20多岁时为自己创造一个美好的未来。但我们就是做不到，不是因为我们不懂事，不是因为我们不关心自己，而是因为我们的大脑正在做它们被训练要做的事情。
Perform a pattern rather than learn a new one. This isn't a discipline problem. It's not a willpower problem, as people may have you believe. It is deeply rooted in psychology, in coping, in how we relate to our emotions, but it can also be rewired using that same psychology if you understand it. So today, I'm going to give you the ultimate. guide to breaking toxic habits from why they form to the four biggest mistakes we make when we're trying to change and what we can do instead. What actually might help us become better people,
执行一种模式，而不是学习新的模式。这不是纪律问题。正如人们可能让你相信的那样，这不是意志力的问题。它深深扎根于心理学、应对机制以及我们如何与自己的情绪建立联系，但如果你理解了它，也可以利用同样的心理学对其进行重新布线。所以今天，我要送给你们终极的打破不良习惯指南，从它们是如何形成的，到我们在试图改变时犯下的四大错误，以及我们可以做些什么来取代它们。什么才能真正帮助我们成为更好的人，
become the people we want to be. Without further ado, let's get into how we can break a toxic habit cycle. We do this at the beginning of every episode, I know, but let's firstly pin down what we mean by a toxic habit cycle. The idea of toxic habits is a very tidy phrase. It could probably mean anything from, I go to bed too late to I can't stop replaying the same relationship pattern. Really what we're referring to is a behavior that is repeated regularly, often automatically, that is reinforced by some kind of reward.
成为我们想要成为的人。废话不多说，让我们进入如何打破不良习惯的循环。我知道我们在每一集的开头都会这样做，但让我们首先明确一下我们所指的不良习惯循环到底是什么。不良习惯这个概念是一个非常整洁的短语。它可能意味着从“我睡得太晚”到“我无法停止重演同一个恋爱模式”的任何事情。实际上我们指的是一种经常重复的行为，通常是自动的，并受到某种奖励的强化。
That can describe either a positive or negative habit. When a habit becomes toxic, really it's just that the outcome that follows the behavior is deeply harmful to us or something that like we actually don't want to occur that doesn't align with who we want to be. A habit also becomes toxic when it crosses three thresholds. We call them the three Cs. C number one, compulsion. You feel an urge to do it often without conscious thought that you find it incredibly hard to fight back against.
这可以形容积极或消极的习惯。当一个习惯变得糟糕时，实际上只是因为行为之后的结果对我们有害，或者是不符合我们真正想要发生的、与我们想成为的人不相符的事情。当一个习惯跨越三个门槛时，它也会变得糟糕。我们称之为三个C。第一个C，强迫（Compulsion）。你感到有一种冲动想要去做，通常是在没有有意识思考的情况下，你发现自己很难去对抗它。
The second C, control. You struggle to stop or limit this behavior. And the final C, the third C, is consequences. It costs you in time, health, money, trust in yourself, in relationships. Now, not every habit we dislike is necessarily toxic in their. it, you know, we can't stop it and it's really harming ourselves. But habit is really toxic when like the cost outweighs the comfort, the comfort of something. When it starts to make your life feel smaller, I think that ability, that questioning of like,
第二个C，控制（Control）。你很难阻止或限制这种行为。最后一个C，第三个C，是后果（Consequences）。它让你付出了时间、健康、金钱、对自己的信任以及人际关系方面的代价。现在，并非我们不喜欢的每一个习惯本质上都是糟糕的。你知道的，我们无法停止它，它确实在伤害我们。但是当代价超过了舒适感时，这个习惯就真的很糟糕了，某种事物的舒适感。当它开始让你的生活感觉越来越小时，我认为那种能力，那种关于“我真的能停下来吗”的质问，当你问自己这个问题时，那就是你应该停下来的信号。当你开始质疑自己的控制力时。
could I actually stop is when you're asking yourself that question, that's when you know you probably should. When you are questioning your control. when you tell yourself this is the last time and you genuinely do mean it but you can't go more than a few days without you know trying to continue to pursue that new habit something is you know probably really bothering you that keeps bringing you back to this thing you don't want to do anymore like a toxic relationship you know you are so committed you genuinely do want to do better and then you get stressed you get lonely you get bored you have a long day and suddenly
当你告诉自己这是最后一次，你是真心实意的，但你坚持不了几天，就会（你知道的）试图继续追求那个新习惯，有些事情（你知道的）可能真的在困扰着你，不断把你拉回到这个你不再想做的事情上，就像一段虐恋，你知道你投入了那么多，你确实想做得更好，然后你感到了压力，你感到了孤独，你感到了无聊，你度过了漫长的一天，突然之间
you're right back in it. This is because in that moment, you are in a territory of what psychologists call the intention behavior gap. This is the space between what we truly do intend to do and what we actually do. A lot of the research suggests that your intentions, your desire to change a behavior only actually predicts around 30 to 40 percent of your actual behaviors. meaning that simply wanting to change, even if you want it bad enough, isn't always enough. It's just not. And that's a really hard thing for people to realize because we like to think that we would be in control and that our emotional decisions would affect our rational ones.
你又回到了原点。这是因为在那一刻，你处于心理学家所说的“意图-行为差距”的领域。这是我们真正打算做的事情与我们实际做的事情之间的空间。许多研究表明，你的意图，即改变某种行为的愿望，实际上只能预测你实际行为的30%到40%左右。这意味着仅仅想要改变，即使你再怎么渴望，也并不总是足够的。它就是不够。这对人们来说是一个很难意识到的事实，因为我们喜欢认为自己可以掌控一切，而且我们的情绪决定会影响理性决定。
The thing is, the more emotionally loaded a habit is the wider the gap between intention and behavior actually becomes, because often that means that means that. this habit is doing the job of regulating your internal emotions and internal systems, not just occupying time. It becomes so psychologically hard to break when there is actually a deep emotion attached to why you are doing these things. You know, toxic habits are more emotional than any other kind of habit. You're not choosing to vape or choosing to overspend or chasing bad relationships because it aligns with your values, because it aligns with your goals, you're doing it because it might be the only way you know to regulate internal states of stress and distress and
问题是，一种习惯的情绪色彩越浓，意图与行为之间的差距实际上就越大，因为通常这意味着，这意味着。这种习惯正在发挥调节你内心的情绪和内部系统的作用，而不仅仅是打发时间。当这些行为背后有着深厚的情感依恋时，要戒掉它是极其困难的。你知道的，不良习惯比任何其他类型的习惯都更具情绪化。你不是因为吸电子烟、过度消费或追逐糟糕的恋爱关系符合你的价值观、符合你的目标而选择这样做，你这样做是因为这可能是你仅知的、用以调节内部的压力、痛苦、
discomfort and loneliness and heartbreak. So that's the biggest sign that a toxic habit is a toxic one. It's deeply emotional. Another sign is the mental choreography that begins to form around the behavior. You start justifying it, hiding it, delaying, thinking about it, becoming preoccupied with it. The amount of thinking about the behavior grows larger than the behavior itself. So it's a living in your head even when you're not doing it. You're thinking about your next drink. You're thinking about avoiding spending. You're thinking about what you should be thinking about so that you don't smoke like those kinds of things. Another subject. indicator is when you're not thinking about doing it and you are doing it, you're slowly
不适、孤独和心碎状态的方法。所以这就是不良习惯之所以是不良习惯的最大信号。它具有深刻的情感色彩。另一个信号是围绕该行为开始形成的心理编排。你开始为它辩护、隐藏它、拖延、思考它、对它全神贯注。思考这种行为的时间超过了行为本身。所以即使你没有在做，它也活在你的脑海里。你在想着你的下一杯酒。你在想着避免消费。你在想着你应该想些什么，这样你就不会抽烟——诸如此类的东西。另一个指示器
escalating the intensity, frequency, severity of the behavior to the point where we really emotional relief becomes harder to find. You have to do more, take more, experience more of this habit in order to produce the same calming feeling that it initially developed. to provide for you. You know, your brain is doing what brains do, repeating what has worked to help you survive uncomfortable feelings and adapting to that comfortable feeling until you need more to produce it.
是当你在没有想它的情况下做这件事，并且你正在做这件事时，你正在慢慢升级该行为的强度、频率、严重程度，直到我们真正很难再找到情感上的解脱。你必须做得更多、接受更多、体验更多这种习惯，才能产生它最初带给你的那种平静感。你知道，你的大脑在做大脑一直在做的事情，重复那些曾帮助你在不舒服的感觉中生存下来的方法，并适应那种舒适感，直到你需要更多的量来产生它。
What's really interesting is that your brain actually doesn't care whether the reward is healthy or harmful. It really doesn't care. It only cares that it provides relief. If something sues to you, then of course it's going to be repeated. if you don't have other mechanisms to help. This process is supported by a very famous theory, a very famous process that we know
真正有趣的是，你的大脑其实并不在乎这种奖励是健康的还是有害的。它真的不在乎。它只在乎它是否能带来解脱。如果某事能安抚你，那么它当然会被重复。如果你没有其他机制来提供帮助。这个过程得到了一个非常著名的理论、一个我们所知的非常著名的过程的支持，
called neuroplasticity. This is your brain's ability to basically physically rewire itself based on experiences. Synaptic connections strengthen through repetition, through long-term potentiation, meaning the more you perform a behavior, the more that you perform a behavior to eliminate distress or to make yourself feel better, the more your brain begins to structure itself around that behavior and make those neural connections a more fortified mental highway. You know, something, again, that comes up a lot when we talk about this is like, how come I want to change so badly and I can't?
叫做神经可塑性。这是大脑根据经历从物理上重塑自身的基能力。突触连接通过重复、通过长期增强作用而得到加强，这意味着你执行一种行为的次数越多，你为了消除痛苦或让自己感觉更好而执行某种行为的次数越多，你的大脑就开始围绕这种行为构建自身，并将这些神经连接变成一条更加牢固的心理高速公路。你知道，再次提到的一点，当我们讨论这个时，人们经常会问：为什么我如此渴望改变却做不到？
Like, is it just me? Is there something wrong with me? Do I just not have the mental strength? And I want to be clear. every single person at some stage in their life has picked up a less than desirable habit. It's not unique to you. It doesn't make you weaker than other people. Some people are just more vulnerable to developing certain habits and to having them stick
这只是我个人的问题吗？我有什么毛病吗？我只是没有心理力量吗？我想明确一点。每个人在人生的某个阶段都曾沾染过不太理想的习惯。这并不是你独有的。这不会让你比其他人更脆弱。有些人只是更容易养成某些习惯并坚持下去，
not because of any moral reasoning, not because they lack discipline, but because of the way that their brain and their emotions have developed and evolved. This is a combination of genetics. It's a combination of genetics, upbringing, trauma. Some of us as well are just more emotionally sensitive than others, me included. Sometimes our emotions just run a little bit louder and so therefore they need something a little bit stronger and more severe to counterbalance them. We feel stress more intensely. Loneliness doesn't just feel uncomfortable, it feels unbearable. Bortem doesn't feel neutral, it feels horrendous.
这并不是因为什么道德上的原因，也不是因为他们缺乏纪律性，而是因为他们的大脑和情绪发展演变的方式。这是遗传的结合。这是基因、成长环境、创伤的结合。我们中的有些人也只是比其他人情感更敏感，包括我在内。有时候我们的情绪只是稍微汹涌一些，因此它们需要更强烈、更严重的东西来与之抗衡。我们对压力的感受更加强烈。孤独不仅让人感到不舒服，更让人感到难以忍受。无聊不觉得是中性的，而觉得是可怕的。
We might refer to this as high emotional reactivity. And research shows that people who experience emotions more strongly are more likely to resort to toxic habits to regulate those feelings. For example, there was a study published in 2019 in the Netherlands that found that people who displayed higher cortisol reactivity were more likely to try to get out of a main. using the same roots that they'd already tried compared to people with a lower cortisol reactivity who engaged in flexible, goal-directed decision-making, who tried new things.
我们可以称之为高情绪反应性。研究表明，那些对情绪体验更强烈的人更有可能求助于不良习惯来调节这些感受。例如，2019年在荷兰发表的一项研究发现，与皮质醇反应较低、进行灵活的、目标导向的决策、尝试新事物的人相比，表现出更高皮质醇反应的人更有可能尝试摆脱困境。使用他们已经尝试过的相同路径。
Can you see where I'm getting with this? Your brain, if you have a high, high cortisol levels, if you're particularly prone to stress, prone to deep emotions, your brain is like, oh my God, it just keeps trying to use the same exit. that doesn't open and doesn't let you re-root, find new paths, build new habits. It just keeps going back to the same places all the time. That's one part of this. There is then the brain's reward system itself. I think we tend to think that we all have the same systems kind of available in our brain.
你明白我的意思了吗？你的大脑，如果你有很高很高的皮质醇水平，如果你特别容易感到压力、容易产生深厚的情绪，你的大脑就会想：天哪，它只是一直试图使用同一个出口。那个打不开、不让你重新规划路线、找到新路径、建立新习惯的出口。它只是一直在回到同一个地方。这是其中的一部分。然后是大脑自身的奖励系统。我认为我们倾向于认为我们大脑中都有相同的系统。
We have the same amygdala, we have the same frontal lobe, the same brain stem, dopamine systems. True but not true. the function, even the form of these systems, does actually vary person to person. Some people have differences in how their brains signal dopamine, particularly when it comes to genes like the DRD2 gene and the COMT gene. If you want to get really scientific with it, if you want to look it up, basically these genes influence dopamine regulation and how strongly your brain responds to rewards and quick dopamine, like the quick dopamine you get from your phone,
我们有相同的杏仁核，我们有相同的前额叶皮层，相同的脑干，多巴胺系统。这既对也不对。这些系统的功能甚至形态，因人而异。有些人在大脑如何传递多巴胺方面存在差异，特别是在涉及DRD2基因和COMT基因等基因时。如果你想用真正科学的方式来探讨，如果你想去查阅它，基本上这些基因会影响多巴胺的调节，以及你的大脑对奖励和快速多巴胺的反应强度，比如你从手机上获得的快速多巴胺，
like the quick dopamine you get from drugs, from alcohol, from nicotine, from impulse purchasing, from impulsive emotional decisions to do with the love. Research shows that certain variants of these genes are associated with more and stronger reward-seeking behavior and faster reinforcement learning. So basically you pick up toxic habits quicker.
比如你从毒品、酒精、尼古丁、冲动购物、与爱情相关的冲动情感决策中获得的快速多巴胺。研究表明，这些基因的某些变异与更强、更多的寻求奖励行为以及更快的强化学习有关。所以基本上你养成不良习惯的速度更快。
Another example, individuals with, lower availability of what we call D2 dopamine receptors may experience not just reward more intensely, but the absence of reward more painfully, so it's harder to break the habit cycle. You get in quicker, it's so much harder to get out. It sounds very complicated. Basically, your brain may just code certain behaviours differently and is more important and more worthy of repeating because of how your brain receives dopamine. It's pretty unfair. Unfortunately, it doesn't, it doesn't mean you can't change. It just means that you have to understand those systems a little bit better and how to navigate the differences in your dopamine systems compared to somebody else when you're trying
另一个例子，拥有我们称之为D2多巴胺受体较低可用性的个体，不仅体验奖励时可能更强烈，而且体验奖励缺失时也更痛苦，因此打破习惯循环变得更加困难。你陷进去的速度更快，要摆脱出来就难得多。这听起来很复杂。基本上，你的大脑可能只是对某些行为进行不同的编码，并且由于你的大脑接收多巴胺的方式，这些行为显得更重要、更值得重复。这很不公平。不幸的是，这并不意味着你不能改变。这只是意味着你必须更好地理解这些系统，并在试图戒除习惯时，弄清楚如何应对你与其他人在多巴胺系统上的差异。
to break a habit. That is the nature element of it. We can't forget the nurture element as well. The environment you grew up in is a huge contributor to the toxic habit cycle. And what it really comes down to is whether you were allowed to express emotion or whether you were required to suppress it. If you grew up in a household where feelings were ignored, mocked, punished, you went to a school where, or you encountered teachers even who told you to be quiet, who thought your emotions were disruptive. If you were bullied and you knew that being out with the emotional would encourage more intense behavior if you were taught to be self-reliant and self-regulate, you are going to learn to manage your emotions in the most direct, quiet way possible,
这是先天因素。我们也不能忘记后天培养的因素。你成长的环境是导致不良习惯循环的一个巨大因素。归根结底，在于你是被允许表达情绪，还是被要求压抑情绪。如果你在一个情感被忽视、嘲笑、惩罚的家庭中长大，或者你上过一所学校，甚至遇到了那些让你闭嘴、认为你的情绪具有破坏性的老师。如果你曾遭受霸凌，并且你知道表现出情绪会招致更激进的行为，如果你被教导要依靠自己和自我调节，你就会学会用最直接、最安静的方式来管理你的情绪，
often using things that end up becoming toxic habits. Basically what this means, the first thing that you encountered that allowed you to soothe yourself because you weren't allowed to soothe yourself outwardly is going to be the thing that your brain keeps coming back to and keeps falling in love with until it replaces it with with something that's even better at suppressing your feelings. So maybe, you know, you were like 12 when you first, someone first, like, offered you weed or somebody first offered you alcohol and it just gets better and better and better. Like, you just keep getting deeper and deeper into the belly of this beast because that was the first thing that made you feel
通常使用那些最终成为不良习惯的东西。基本上这意味着，你遇到的第一件允许你自我安慰的事情（因为你不被允许向外寻求安慰）将会成为你大脑不断回归并不断迷恋的东西，直到它被一种在压抑你情绪方面表现得更好的东西所取代。所以也许，你知道，当你大约12岁时，有人第一次向你提供大麻或酒精，它就会变得越来越好。就像，你只是不断深入这个怪兽的腹地，因为那是第一个让你感觉好点的东西。
okay. What's hard is that these habits are often built on years of self-repression and self-silencing, so they feel more familiar than feeling our feelings. When a habit becomes tied to your way of coping, to your identity, to your sense of self, it's harder to let go of, not because the behavior is even necessarily pleasurable, but because it feels like a familiar part of who you are. And your brain will always choose the known over the unknown, even when the known hurts us. Okay. Now that we kind of understand why these habits form, why they are so hard to shake, let's talk about the mistakes people make when trying to change them and what you can do instead after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
困难的是，这些习惯通常建立在多年自我压抑和自我压制的基础上，所以它们比感受我们的情绪感觉更熟悉。当一个习惯与你的应对方式、你的身份、你的自我意识联系在一起时，就更难放手，不是因为这种行为本身有多么令人愉悦，而是因为它感觉像是你熟悉的一部分。而且大脑总是会选择已知而非未知，即使已知会伤害我们。好了。既然我们已经明白了这些习惯是如何形成的，为什么它们如此难以戒除，接下来让我们在短暂的休息后，聊聊人们在试图改变时犯下的错误，以及你可以做些什么来代替。2%.这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题，都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross
让自己经历一些磨难，你将会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己迎接新生。请收听“2%”。即数字TWO。在爱荷华电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯
double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim. Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系。好吧，你可以在“回首过往”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔一起畅谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备谈论可卡因，但只是为了让你们所有人知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade.
是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在爱荷华电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回首过往”。欢迎来到我的新播客“艰难求生”，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的经验。
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我在心理健康领域的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。但我们仍在追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free, I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是做一个好人。和我（科尔·盖恩斯）一起，在我的新播客“艰难求生”中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费爱荷华电台应用。搜索“艰难求生”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己身处父子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这引发了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你对这个特定的测试做了两次手脚，在很大程度上。我对测试做了一次手脚。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过相同事情的男人。
Greg Alespian and Michael Nanchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·南奇尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“受困之爱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
请在爱荷华电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“受困之爱”播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这一季全新的“女朋友们”中……天哪，这是同一个男人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上呢？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So if you want to quit procrastinating, quit getting sucked into your phone constantly, quit eating food that doesn't make you feel good, here are the four common mistakes you're probably going to come up against initially. Mistake number one, when most of us try to break a toxic habit, we tend to approach it with this really great intensity,
请在爱荷华电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“女朋友们。相信我，宝贝”。所以，如果你想戒掉拖延症，戒掉总是沉迷于手机的习惯，戒掉吃那些让你感觉不舒服的食物，以下是你最初可能会遇到的四个常见错误。错误一，当我们大多数人试图打破不良习惯时，我们往往会带着非常强大的强度去应对，
which is amazing. We're very motivated. We have this like, this ends now idea. We suddenly decide that tomorrow will be different. We will be stronger, more disciplined, more determined than ever before, and that will be it. We will be done with this. We will be free of this habit.
这太棒了。我们非常有动力。我们有一种“这一切到此为止”的想法。我们突然决定明天会有所不同。我们会比以往任何时候都更坚强、更有纪律性、更有决心，然后事情就这样结束了。我们将摆脱这一切。我们将摆脱这个习惯。
We genuinely mean it. The thing is, though, willpower is actually a short-term resource, not a long-term fuel source. Willpower isn't designed to carry you long-term. It's designed to be the spark. And it is deeply impacted by sleep, stress, hormones, mood, hunger. So if you're relying on sheer effort to overcome a behavior, that is an automatic part of your brain,
我们是真心实意的。但问题是，意志力其实是一种短期资源，而不是长期的燃料来源。意志力不是为了支撑你长期作战而设计的。它被设计用来成为火花。并且它深受睡眠、压力、荷尔蒙、情绪和饥饿的影响。因此，如果你依靠纯粹的努力来克服一种属于大脑自动部分的行为，
you are literally fighting your neurologically ingrained patterns with a fleeting feeling of desire to change. And what often happens is that life happens. You know, you get tired, you have a bad day, something triggers you emotionally, and crucially, you may have willpower, but what you don't have are other skills or habits to manage the feeling. and suddenly we find ourselves right back where we started, repeating the thing we swore we wouldn't.
你实际上是在用一种短暂的改变愿望，去对抗你神经系统根深蒂固的模式。而经常发生的情况是，生活总有意外。你知道，你累了，你度过了糟糕的一天，某些事情触动了你的情绪，最重要的是，你可能有意志力，但你没有的是管理这种感觉的其他技能或习惯。突然之间，我们发现自己回到了原点，重复着我们发誓不会再做的事。
And then we also fall into this self-blame cycle. This is all my fault. I wasn't strong enough. No, it's because when you created this plan, you didn't plan with an alternative in mind. You can't just expect yourself not to scroll if you don't know what to do instead. If you don't have a book you're interested in, you don't have a project you're working on, you don't have a diary to write in. You have to have a plan B. You know, a plan B habit for smoking maybe chewing gum. A plan B habit for always saying yes to plans, maybe putting standing appointments with yourself in your calendar. You have to have alternatives available.
然后我们又陷入了自责的循环。这都是我的错。我不够坚强。不，这是因为当你制定这个计划时，你没有考虑到备选方案。如果你不知道该做些什么来代替，你就不能指望自己不刷手机。如果你没有一本感兴趣的书，如果你没有一个正在进行的项目，如果你没有一本可以写日记的笔记本。你必须制定B计划。你知道的，抽烟的B计划习惯或许是嚼口香糖。总是对计划说“好”的B计划习惯，或许是在你的日程表上为自己安排固定的预约。你必须有备选方案。
Another powerful thing we can do to counteract this error is adjust your environment so that the habit that you don't want to do becomes harder to perform than the habit that you do want to do. Your brain loves the path of least resistance. So create some resistance for the things you don't want to engage in and reduce resistance for the things you do want to engage in. If alcohol isn't in your house, you can't reach for it. If the phone is in the other room, you can't hit snooze. If you stock your fridge full of bright, yummy, colorful food, you're less likely to
我们可以采取的另一个有力措施来抵消这种错误是调整你的环境，使你不想做的习惯比你想做的习惯更难执行。你的大脑喜欢阻力最小的路径。因此，为你不想参与的事情制造一些阻力，并减少你想要参与的事情的阻力。如果家里没有酒，你就拿不到。如果手机在另一个房间，你就无法按贪睡键。如果你把冰箱里塞满明亮、美味、色彩缤纷的食物，你就更不可能
order takeout. So by creating less friction between you and your ability to carry out more positive habits, these are the behaviours that are more likely to be done. Our second stumbling point is that we tend to you know, not just rely on willpower, but start too big. We set perfect, dramatic rules for ourselves, often multiple rules at the same time and we go cold turkey all at once. We plan to do multiple things every single day and our brain is overloaded. This is why things like the 75 hard challenge are so difficult mentally and why the fail rate is like one estimate I saw was it's over 95%. There's too many rules to follow all at once that differ from your norm and differ from your baseline. I have so many thoughts about the 75 hard challenge. We could do an entire episode on it,
点外卖了。因此，通过减少你与执行更积极习惯的能力之间的摩擦，这些行为更有可能被实现。我们的第二个绊脚石是，我们往往（你知道的）不仅依赖意志力，而且一开始步子迈得太大。我们给自己设定了完美、戏剧化的规则，通常是同时设定多条规则，并且一次性彻底戒除。我们计划每天做多项事情，导致大脑超载。这就是为什么像“75硬挑战”（75 hard challenge）这样的事情在精神上如此困难，以及为什么失败率极高（我看到的一个估计是超过95%）。有太多规则需要同时遵循，这些规则偏离了你的常态，偏离了你的基准。我对“75硬挑战”有很多想法。我们可以专门做一集来聊聊它，
but psychologists know if you want long-term change rather than an incremental, one off change, we as humans don't respond well to dramatic shifts. We respond to consistency and baby steps. When the bar is set at perfection, the first slip up feels detrimental. So instead of continuing, we abandon the effort altogether. Not because we're incapable of change, but because we've made the terms of change impossible to sustain. How do we counter out that?
但心理学家知道，如果你想要长期的改变，而不是渐进式的、一次性的改变，我们人类对戏剧性的转变反应并不好。我们对规律性和微小的步伐反应良好。当把标准定在完美时，第一次失误就会让人觉得是致命的打击。因此，我们没有继续下去，而是彻底放弃了努力。不是因为我们没有改变的能力，而是因为我们把改变的条件设得无法维持。我们如何对此进行反击？
make just one small rule for yourself. One rule at a time. I won't vape until midday. I can scroll on my phone, but only in this position, only for one hour. I can drink, just not on weekdays. I can buy things I want, but only after I sell something I already own. One rule. One rule that minimizes to begin with and take that one rule seriously.
为自己只定一个小规则。一次一条规则。我中午之前不抽电子烟。我可以刷手机，但只能在这个姿势下，只能刷一小时。我可以喝酒，但工作日不行。我可以买想要的东西，但只能在我卖掉一件已有物品之后。一条规则。一条最初能将要求降到最低的规则，并且认真对待那一条规则。
then you can build from that platform of self-trust, of proving to yourself that you can do it, and you can build the house one brick at a time, rather than starting with the roof, rather than starting with like a complete overhaul that you don't actually have the mental resources yet to see through. The third common pitfall that most people do fall into is they try to change the behavior. We don't address the emotion that drives it. You know, we decide to stop doom spending, but we don't ask, you know, what am I avoiding my spending all this money? We want to stop drinking when we feel socially anxious, but we don't explore, you know, what is it about meeting people that feel so uncomfortable?
然后你就可以在自我信任的平台上建立起来，向自己证明你能做到，并且你可以一块砖一块砖地建造这座房子，而不是从屋顶开始，也不是从一项你实际上还没有足够的心理资源去完成的彻底彻底的改造开始。大多数人陷入的第三个常见陷阱是，他们试图改变行为。我们没有去解决驱动这种行为的情绪。你知道的，我们决定停止冲动消费，但我们没有问（你知道的），我花这么多钱到底在逃避什么？当我们感到社交焦虑时，我们想要戒酒，但我们没有去探索（你知道的），关于结识他人，究竟是什么让人感觉如此不舒服？
What am I actually afraid of? If the habit is soothing something within us, removing the habit without understanding the beast that it's actually trying to slay is pretty pointless. Your brain's just going to return to the fastest source of relief it knows. The alternative is obviously therapy, but also, confronting the fear that the habit is asking you to avoid. Here are like some initial questions that you can just sit with right now to maybe just give yourself a few answers.
我到底在害怕什么？如果这种习惯是在抚慰我们内心的某种东西，那么在不了解它真正想要斩除的野兽之前就戒掉这个习惯是毫无意义的。你的大脑只会回到它所知道的最快的解脱源泉。替代方案显然是心理治疗，但也包括勇敢面对习惯要求你逃避的恐惧。这里有一些你可以现在就静心思考的初步问题，也许能给你一些答案。
What are you afraid might happen if you don't engage in this behavior? And why does this outcome scare you so much? What need is this habit trying to meet? Comfort, connection, control, maybe distraction. What are some other ways I can give that to myself? What would it look like to face that uncomfortable feeling? Would I survive it? Would I survive it even for just 30 seconds?
如果你不进行这种行为，你害怕会发生什么？为什么这个结果让你如此害怕？这种习惯正试图满足什么需求？舒适、连接、控制，也许是分心。我还有什么其他方式可以给自己提供这些？面对那种不舒服的感觉会是什么样子？我能熬过去吗？哪怕只熬30秒我也能熬过去吗？
This kind of brings us to our final point. We often can't quit a toxic habit because we tell ourselves that we're bad for doing it in the first place rather than acknowledging why we are trying so hard to escape. You know, I know people have different ideas on this. People think tough love works, shame works. You have to get to your tipping point. You need to stop making excuses for yourself. But we know what the evidence actually says.
这把我们引向了最后一点。我们经常无法戒掉不良习惯，是因为我们一开始就告诉自己做这件事的我们很坏，而不是去承认为什么我们如此努力地想要逃避。你知道，我知道大家对此有不同的看法。人们认为严厉的爱管用，羞耻感管用。你必须达到你的临界点。你需要停止为自己找借口。但我们知道证据实际是怎么说的。
Having unconditional love for yourself and your mistakes in this process creates the internal emotional environment to fortify you from the inside. To give you that sense of trust and love that you can try time and time again, you can fail, it's okay. and you understand why this is happening so that you can provide alternatives. So those are the pitfalls. What are some of the other things that we can do? One of the most effective plans of attack if you want to change a toxic habit cycle is identity-based change.
在这个过程中，对你自己和你的错误抱有无条件的爱，会创造出一个内部的情感环境，从内部坚固你。给你那种信任和爱，让你能够一次又一次地尝试，你可以失败，没关系。而且你明白为什么会发生这一切，这样你就可以提供替代方案。这些就是陷阱。我们还可以做些什么其他事情呢？如果你想改变不良习惯的循环，最有效的进攻计划之一就是基于身份的改变。
Behavior follows identity, not the other way around. When you begin to see yourself as someone who is capable of change, who is learning new things, who is showing up differently, the behavior begins to allow. line with that story. If you want to stay within the confines of, I'm just someone who's impulsive, I'm just someone who's lazy, this is just who I am, and you don't challenge those core beliefs, you are not going to change. You need to flip the script and challenge the parts of your identity that have fallen into these patterns, like, who believe that this is just who they are. So what I want you to do is write down five statements about the kind of person you want to be
行为遵循身份，而不是相反。当你开始把自己看作是一个有能力改变、正在学习新事物、以不同方式出现的人时，行为就会开始符合那个故事。如果你想停留在这样的框架里：我只是个冲动的人，我只是个懒惰的人，我这就是我，而你不去挑战这些核心信念，你就不会改变。你需要扭转剧本，挑战你身份中陷入这些模式的部分，比如，那些认为这就是他们本来面目的人。所以我想让你做的是，写下五句关于你想成为什么样的人的陈述
and the kind of person who would beat this habit or who wouldn't engage in it. Things like, I'm someone who values health. I am someone who is in control. I'm someone who is naturally a good spender. If you've read atomic habits, which I'm sure a lot of you have, this will sound familiar to you, identity-based change, believing first that you are the kind of person who performs its behavior before attempting it will help you do it. But, you know, the science and the research backs this up. When a new behavior feels aligned with your identity or your desired identity, you are more likely to do it.
以及那种能够克服这个习惯或不会沾染它的人。比如：我是一个重视健康的人。我是一个能掌控自己的人。我是一个天生善于理财的人。如果你读过《原子习惯》，我确信你们很多人都读过，这听取会让你觉得很熟悉：基于身份的改变，在尝试之前首先相信自己是那种会执行这种行为的人，将有助于你做到这一点。但是，你知道，科学和研究支持这一点。当一种新行为感觉与你的身份或你想要的身份一致时，你更有可能去做它。
Another way we can teach our brain a new pathway is through mental rehearsal. There is so much research on the overlap of neural circuits that we use when imagining doing something and actually carrying out that thing. For example, a 2018 paper from the University of Colorado, Boulder, found that mentally imagining a fear-inducing situation helps people process and unlearn that fear just as much as being in that situation themselves in-person, having that in-person exposure. You know something crazy that I heard the other day? I cannot remember where I heard this, but this woman was talking about how people who, exercise a lot. When they were put into an experimental condition when they were asked to visualize themselves exercising, visualize themselves lifting heavy weights for 20 minutes a day. When they came back after not exercising for a number of weeks, they were actually stronger.
我们可以教给大脑新途径的另一种方法是通过心理彩排。关于我们在想象做某事和实际执行该事时所使用的神经回路的重叠，有大量的研究。例如，科罗拉多大学博尔德分校 2018 年的一篇论文发现，在心理上想象一个引起恐惧的情境，有助于人们处理和消除这种恐惧，其效果就像亲自处于该情境中、进行面对面的接触一样。你知道我前几天听到的疯狂的事吗？我不记得我在哪里听到这个了，但这个女人在谈论那些经常锻炼的人。当他们被置于一个实验条件中，要求他们想象自己锻炼，想象自己每天花 20 分钟举起重物时。当他们在几周没有锻炼后回来时，他们实际上变得更强壮了。
Their muscles actually showed a response to these positive thoughts they'd had about their strength and about their ability. That's quills. That's quills. crazy to me. That's wild. So just picturing yourself being able to beat this habit, picturing yourself, denying yourself the behavior, saying no, pausing. That rehearsal, like, that is not wasted effort. Because the moment that that cue actually arrives and you actually encounter it and you have imagined yourself being able to avoid it, say no to it in the past, you have a, mental script to follow. This is the thing.
他们的肌肉实际上对他们关于力量和能力的积极想法做出了反应。这太疯狂了。这对我来说太疯狂了。太离谱了。所以，只要想象自己能够改掉这个习惯，想象自己拒绝这种行为，说不，暂停。这种彩排，绝对不是浪费精力。因为当那个线索真正到来，你真正遇到它，并且你过去曾想象过自己能够避免它、对它说不时，你就有了一个可以遵循的心智剧本。就是这样。
I feel like we just keep coming back to this, micro movements, micro moments, microchanges. Just these small acts of resistance are so powerful. It's also why people talk about the five-minute rule when we want to break toxic habit cycles. If you can just avoid the toxic habit for five minutes, you can avoid it for five days, five years for the rest of your life.
我觉得我们一直在回到这一点，微动作、微时刻、微改变。仅仅这些微小的抵抗行为就具有如此强大的力量。这也是为什么当我们想要打破有毒习惯循环时，人们会谈论五分钟规则。如果你能把那个有毒的习惯避免五分钟，你就能避免五天、五年，甚至余下的人生。
just avoid it for five minutes. And when that's done, five more minutes, five more minutes, even 30 seconds. The research behind this basically says that five minutes, even just a small chunk of time, is enough for your frontal lobe to switch on or for your conscious decision making to overwhelm, outweigh, interrupt your unconscious decision making. We've spoken a lot about how the reason toxic habits remain is because we've never actually asked our brain to do something differently or relate to our emotions differently. And so it's become an automatic response. Time is the easiest way to counteract something
只要避免它五分钟。当这完成后，再来五分钟，再来五分钟，甚至 30 秒。这背后的研究基本上表明，五分钟，哪怕只是一小段时间，也足够让你的额叶开启，或者让你的有意识决策压倒、超越、打断你的无意识决策。我们已经讨论了很多关于为什么有害习惯会保留下来的原因，因为我们从未真正要求过大脑做一些不同的事情，或者以不同的方式与我们的情绪建立联系。所以它变成了一种自动反应。时间是抵消自动且瞬间发生的事情的最简单方法
that is automatic and happening instantaneously. If you can just give yourself a few seconds, a few minutes, the rational executive functioning part of your brain will switch on and will allow you to really start questioning from a value point. of you, do I want to do this? Do I actually want to do this? Or is there something else I can do? The final way you can really engage in breaking a toxic habit is to learn that long-term gratification is so much more enjoyable than immediate gratification. When you truly wait for something, work for something, want something, the reward is so much sweeter. When you only drink on a Saturday, you know, the alcohol suddenly tastes better.
如果你能给自己几秒钟、几分钟，你大脑中理性的执行功能部分就会开启，并允许你真正开始从价值观的角度去质疑：我想这么做吗？我真的想这么做吗？还是我能做点别的？真正打破有害习惯的最后一种方法是了解长远满足感比即时满足感要愉快得多。当你真正等待某事、为某事努力、渴望某事时，回报是如此甜美。你知道，当你只在周六喝酒时，酒精突然尝起来更美味了。
When you only buy items that you really care about and that you know you're going to wear, you treasure them more. When you delay something for a more fruitful, worthwhile, exciting outcome, you become addicted to this idea of hard work and effort towards something bigger. So what you need to do is give yourself three rewards in the next three months. A reward for not doing the behavior for one week, a reward for not doing the behavior for one month, and a reward for not doing the behavior for three months. Setting, and they can't be small of these rewards, by the way.
当你只买那些你真正关心并且知道你会穿的物品时，你会更珍惜它们。当你为了更有成效、更值得、更令人兴奋的结果而推迟某事时，你会对这种朝着更宏大目标努力的辛勤工作和付出的想法上瘾。所以你需要做的是在接下来的三个月里给自己三个奖励。不进行这种行为一周的奖励，不进行这种行为一个月的奖励，以及不进行这种行为三个月的奖励。顺便说一句，设定这些奖励不能太小。
Like they have to be significant. And you have to ensure that you're going to deliver them to yourself. but that you're going to wait. Whether it's like an item of clothing, it's a trip, it's an experience, it's, I don't know, a moment of indulgence, whatever it is, you have to start to train your brain and show your brain, show yourself that when you wait for things, they feel better by giving yourself just this opportunity, this three-month exercise to prove that to yourself. You will only learn this feeling, this feeling of long-term gratification through a
就像它们必须具有重要意义一样。你必须确保你会把它们兑现给自己，但你必须等待。不管是衣物、是一次旅行、是一次体验、还是我不知道，是一刻的纵容，无论是什么，你必须开始训练你的大脑并向你的大脑展示、向你自己展示，当你等待事情发生时，通过给自己这样一个机会、这个为期三个月的练习来向自己证明，它们感觉会更好。你只会通过一种体验来了解这种感觉，即长远满足感的感觉。
experience. It's the only way that you will know that the feelings are different. So challenge yourself to do this exercise. Write down the three rewards you're going to give yourself. Make sure they're big enough and then use all of these other tips that we've given you to get to those points to chase that more enriching feeling. I want to remind you this is going to take time. There will be days when your old habit wins. And this is where the most important part of all comes in. Relapse, is not the end of the process, people will tell you it's part of it. You do not unlearn a pathway in one quick motion. There are entire industries worth billions of dollars supporting, you know, built on the fact that people cannot break toxic habits like the ones that you are injuring. The thing is,
这是你了解这些感觉不同的唯一途径。所以挑战自己去做这个练习。写下你要给自己的三个奖励。确保它们足够大，然后利用我们给你的所有其他提示来达到这些目标，去追求那种更丰富的感觉。我想提醒你，这需要时间。总会有你的旧习惯获胜的日子。这就是最重要部分登场的地方。复发并不是过程的终结，人们会告诉你它是其中的一部分。你不会在一个快速动作中就忘掉一条通路。有整个价值数十亿美元的行业在支持着，你知道，它们建立在人们无法戒除像你正在遭受的这种有害习惯的事实之上。问题是，
is that despite that, you will still win. Like I know it, you will still beat this. You want to. You want to. You want to and you're putting things into place to help yourself and you're taking advice on it. And there is a part of you who deep down knows that your life is going to be better because you are changing this about yourself. You have a deep investment in your future that only someone who knows they're going to win has. You care enough about this and you're putting in the work. So you're going to be willing to try and try. again and try again and learn every single time you maybe fail and know that you have to sometimes have those failures to build the future strength to be able to beat this and to be able to replace
尽管如此，你仍然会赢。就像我所知道的，你仍然会战胜这个。你想赢。你想赢。你想赢，你正在采取措施帮助自己，并且你正在接受相关的建议。潜意识里有那么一部分的你深知，因为你正在改变自己的这一点，你的生活会变得更好。你对自己的未来有着深厚的投入，只有那些知道自己会赢的人才会有。你在乎这个，并且你正在付出努力。所以你将愿意一次又一次地尝试，并在每次可能失败时吸取教训，并且知道有时你必须经历这些失败来建立未来的力量，以便能够战胜这个困难，并能够替代
this toxic habit with better ones. If there's one thing you take away from this episode, it is that you cannot do anything, change anything about yourself you will never be able to if you do not change how you relate to yourself. And that is tender work. It asks you to look at the parts of you that have been surviving in the best ways they know how. It asks you to be honest about what you avoid, your patterns, your needs, and recognize that your current habits are nothing more than a Band-Aid. They are not helping you. And the version of you that you want to be, who you want to see, who you care about enough
这个有害习惯，用更好的习惯取而代之。如果你从这集节目中获得了一点启示，那就是你无法做任何事，无法改变关于自己的任何事——如果你不改变你与自己的关系，你就永远无法做到这一点。这是一项温柔的工作。它要求你审视自己那些一直在以它们所知道的最好方式生存的部分。它要求你诚实地面对你所逃避的事情、你的模式、你的需求，并认识到你目前的习惯不过是一个创可贴。它们对你没有帮助。而你想成为的那个版本的你，你想看到的、你在乎到
to be wanting to change, wanting to change right now, really needs you to be understanding of the place you're in here in this moment, this starting line position where you have everything to gain and everything to lose and you're doing it anyways and you deserve tenderness and you deserve compassion for the habits that you've built so far to survive. I hope that that is like the message you really take away from this. Thank you so much for listening. If you have made it this far, I appreciate you listening to the full episode. I'm appreciative that I have kept your attention for this long.
想要改变、现在就想改变的你，真的很需要你理解你此时此刻所处的地方，这个拥有一切可以获得、一切可以失去的起跑线位置，无论如何你都在这样做，你值得拥有温柔，你也值得为自己为了生存到目前为止所建立的习惯报以同情。我希望这就是你真正从中汲取的信息。非常感谢你的收听。如果你听到了这里，我很感激你能收听完整的一集节目。我很感激我能吸引你这么长时间的注意力。
Leave a little message down below. What's the toxic habit you're trying to break? I bet that there will be other people who are also in the same boat. I also want to remind you that this episode was also on YouTube. So if you prefer watching future episodes rather than listening to them, you can go and subscribe there. We are also on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to keep up to date with what we're doing behind the scenes with really cool
在下方留言吧。你正试图改掉的坏习惯是什么？我敢打赌，还会有其他人也处于同样的处境。我还想提醒大家，这集节目也在 YouTube 上。所以如果你更喜欢看未来的节目而不是听它们，你可以在那里订阅。我们也在 Instagram 上，账号是 That Psychology Podcast。如果你想了解我们在幕后的最新动态，比如今年 12 月即将做客的非常酷的
guests that we have coming up this December or if you have an episode suggestion, you can DM me there. Special thanks today to Libby Colbert for her research contributions to this episode. Big shout out to Libby. She is just the legend behind the scenes and we appreciate her. But until next time, stay safe. Be kind, especially today. Be gentle with yourself.
嘉宾，或者如果你有什么节目建议，你可以在那里给我发私信。今天特别感谢利比·科尔伯特（Liby Colbert）对本期节目的研究贡献。向利比大声致敬。她简直是幕后的传奇，我们感谢她。但直到下次，保重。保持善良，尤其是今天。对自己温柔一点。
And we will talk very, very soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a hear, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
我们很快就会再聊。在 Look Back at it 播客中。1979 年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过难关的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games.
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84 年真是疯狂的一年。我的意思是，这是一个疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，而在任何其他地方进行这些对话其实并不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习艰难的方式。2023 年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，欧文斯女士，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trapped》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健康和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
让自己经历一些困难，你就会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 2%。也就是 TWO percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他不会就这样逃脱的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证是真人。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。